Let's see. You work for southwest airlines
and you see a huge number of customers
requesting different food choices
like a Greek chicken salad on flights.
If you brought this request
to the CEO of the company,
he would probably show you this
quote southwest the low fare airline.
How will offering a Greek salad on our
flights help keep us as the low fare
airline?
This is the core of the southwest
business model broken down to its simplest
possible element. If it doesn't help
keep us as the low fare airline,
we are not going to do it in this way.
Every decision can be put through the
filter of how will it affect our core
message.
You might notice that many workers at
southwest are able to be more lighthearted
and have fun. If you want to
sing a song over the inner calm,
it doesn't affect our core,
but if you decided to throw confetti
after every landing requiring a cleanup
crew, now you are affecting
the core of the business.
When making a complex idea simple,
you need to make it as compact as
possible while maintaining the core of the
idea when done correctly.
This can be incredibly powerful.
The idea of a proverb captures
this concept perfectly.
It condenses lessons from a lifetime of
experience into a phrase like a burden.
The hand is worth two in the bush.
A phrase that takes five seconds to read
could take years to really implement in
your life,
but how do we get to the core of an idea
without dumbing it down and making it
meaningless? The book takes us through an
exercise of trying to memorize letters.
Try and remember as many
letters as you can. J. F, K, F,
B. I. N. T, O, u.
P.
S. N. A. S. A. I. R. S. Now listen to
the same exact letters in the same order,
but just read a little
bit differently. J. F,
k,
F.
B. I. N. A. T. O. U. P.
S. N. A. S. A. I. R. S.
Now you could probably memorize a lot
more with the first sequence you're trying
to remember rod data with the
second you are memorizing concepts.
There is no way the concept of JFK
is more simple than the letters Kjf,
but your tapping into a deeply
internalized concept of JFK.
The memory work has
already been done here.
A complex idea is chunked as one concept.
Well Keiji F makes our brain trying
to remember three unrelated concepts.
If you find yourself stuck,
deciding between conveying
accuracy or accessibility,
always go for accessibility.
It's like when a teacher tries to explain
the concept of electrons to a six year
old, they will teach them by
comparing it to the orbits of planets.
Even though is not totally accurate.
That is because the concept of orbiting
planets is already accessible in their
minds.
This is not dumbing down the message,
but stripping the idea to its main
essence. When you're doing creative work,
it can be painful to leave out incredibly
valuable information that is not the
core message.
Learn to relentlessly prioritize and make
your ideas as profound and compact as
you can.
Try to create proverbs with your work.